GOING TO BE A MEDICAL STUDENT
WHICH IS PROBABLY WHY YOU CAN
PRONOUNCE ALL THOSE WORDS VERY
WELL.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT.
NOW TO OUR OTHER TOP STRIKE OF A
HUGE FOREIGN POLICY WEEK FOR THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
HISTORIC OPENING OF U.S. EMBASSY
IN JERUSALEM IS MET WITH VIOLENT
PROTESTS ALONG ISRAEL'S BORDER
WITH GAZA.
DOZENS OF PALESTINIANS ARE DEAD,
AND THOUSANDS MORE REPORTEDLY
INJURED.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
MOVING FORWARD TO TRY TO
DENUCLEARIZE NORTH KOREA.
EARLIER IN JERUSALEM, THE
PRESIDENT ADDRESSED THE CROWD
WITH A VIDEO MESSAGE PRAISING
OUR COUNTRY'S FRIENDS AND ALLIES
OUR COUNTRY'S FRIENDS AND ALLIE
ALLIES.
>> ISRAEL IS A SOVEREIGN NATION
WITH THE RIGHT LIKE EVERY OTHER
SOVEREIGN NATION TO DETERMINE
ITS OWN CAPITAL.
YET FOR MANY YEARS, WE FAIL TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE OBVIOUS.
THE PLAIN REALITY THAT ISRAEL'S
CAPITAL IS JERUSALEM.
THE UNITED STATES REMAINS FULLY
COMMITTED TO FACILITATING A
LASTING PEACE AGREEMENT, AND WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
STATUS QUO AT JERUSALEM'S HOLY
SITES, INCLUDING AT THE TEMPLE
MOUNT, ALSO KNOWN AS AVRAM AL
SHARIF.
>> Dana: SAYING THAT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE VIOLENCE
RESTS SQUARELY WITH HAMAS.
CHECK OUT PETER ALEXANDER.
>> WE BELIEVE HAMAS IS
RESPONSIBLE.
>> IS THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
BEYOND THAT ON THE ISRAELI
AUTHORITY?
>> WE BELIEVE HAMAS IS AN
ORGANIZATION IS ENGAGED IN
CYNICAL ACTUALLY BEEN TO THESE
DEPTHS.
>> Dana: STARTING WITH THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE DAY OR SOME
IN THE MEDIA'S TAKE ON IT.
>> Jesse: KIND OF AN ASININE
INNUENDO THAT THEY ARE MURDERING
INNOCENT CIVILIANS.
INSULTING.
HE IS BETTER THAN THAT BECAUSE
HE'S A PRETTY DECENT REPORTER,
SO I DON'T HAVE MUCH TO SAY
ABOUT THAT.
WHAT IS MAKING TRUMP SO
SUCCESSFUL IS HOW HE BECAME
SUCCESSFUL AS A BUSINESSMAN IN
THESE TRANSLATING INTO BEING A
POLITICIAN.
HE IS A MAN OF HIS WORD AND HE
IS A MAN OF ACTION.
THAT'S WHY HE IS RACKING UP
THESE TANGIBLE VICTORIES.
IN 1995, CONGRESS PASSED OUR
RELOCATION ACT FOR JERUSALEM.
IT TOOK THREE PRESIDENTS WHO DID
NOTHING AND STOOD BY NOW.
IVANKA AND JARED ARE THERE TODAY
FOR THE OPENING, AND THIS
COINCIDING WITH THE 70TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF THE STATE OF ISRAEL.
OF COURSE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A
LITTLE CLASHING YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE SOME BLOWUPS AT THE BORDER.
THAT'S TO BE EXPECTED BECAUSE
JERUSALEM I BELIEVE IS THE THIRD
MOST HOLY CITY FOR ISLAM.
THAT WILL BLOW OVER, AND YOU'LL
GET THE PEACE PROCESS BACK ON
TRACK.
I THINK JERROD IS DOING A PRETTY
NICE JOB.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THE KUSHNER
ACCORD.
HOPEFULLY WILL HAVE THAT DONE,
MAYBE ANOTHER NOVELL PEACE PRIZE
THAT JUAN CAN BE ENVIOUS OF.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT, WHEN HE
DOES THESE THINGS, IT'S BECAUSE
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT OFFENDING
THE STATUS QUO.
I MEAN, IF YOU LOOK WHAT
HAPPENED WITH HIM DEFEATING THE
CALIPHATE OR THEM, THE NATO
COUNTRIES PONYING UP THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
OR TEARING UP NAFTA ARE
RENEGOTIATING NAFTA.
THESE KIND OF THINGS, HE DOESN'T
REALLY CARE ABOUT THE BALL BACK.
HE ALSO SAYS THE OBVIOUS.
JERUSALEM IS OBVIOUSLY THE
CAPITAL OF ISRAEL.
IT'S OBVIOUS WE NEED A BORDER
WITH MEXICO.
IT'S OBVIOUS CHINA IS STEALING
JOBS.
IT'S OBVIOUS NORTH KOREA NEEDS
TO BE DEALT WITH AND NOW HE'S
DOING THAT WITH THE MAXIMUM
CAMPAIGN OF PRESSURE OR
DIPLOMATICALLY, MILITARILY, EVEN
THROUGH TWITTER.
HE HAS BROUGHT THEM TO THE
TABLE.
THEY ARE GOING TO END THE KOREAN
WAR.
I THINK THEY ARE TOTALLY
IMPLODING THEIR UNDERGROUND
NUCLEAR TESTING FACILITY.
THEY ARE SEALING OFF THE
ENTRANCES.
IT'S A HUGE STEP, RELEASING THE
HOSTAGES IS A HUGE STEP.
NOW YOU HAVE THIS SUMMIT IN
SINGAPORE.
IT LOOKS POSITIVE.
WE'LL GO IN THERE WITH CLEAR AND
OPEN EYES.
I THINK "THE FIVE" SHOULD MAYBE
GO TO SINGAPORE AND BROADCAST.
WE COULD ALL MAKE THE TRIP.
>> Dana: DO YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT VENEZUELA WHILE WE ARE AT
IT?
MUCH EVERYPLACE.
I WOULD TAKE ISSUE WITH OTHER
PRESIDENTS DOING NOTHING.
I THINK THIS PRESIDENT WAS ABLE
TO SAY, THE CONVENTIONAL WISDOM
THAT THERE WOULD BE MASS
PROTESTS AND VIOLENCE THAT WAS
AWESOME OF TODAY BUT IT'S NOT
THE PARADE OF HORRIBLES PEOPLE
ANTICIPATED, KIMBERLY.
IT'S POSSIBLE THE PEACE PROCESS
COULD GET BACK ON TRACK.
THERE'S A BETTER PATH FOR THE
PALESTINIANS IF THEY WANTED.
THE OTHER THING THAT HAS CHANGED
IS ALSO YOU HAVE NOW OTHER
COUNTRIES LIKE SAUDI TELLING THE
PALESTINIANS YOU NEED TO GET ON
BOARD WITH WHAT'S GOING HAPPEN
HERE.
IF YOU WANT A TWO-STATE
SOLUTION, STEP UP.
>> Kimberly: I THINK YOU MAKE
AN IMPORTANT POINT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT MOMENT IN
AMERICAN AND ISRAELI HISTORY IN
TERMS OF HOW IT AFFECTS THAT
AREA OF THE WORLD, IT'S BEEN
COMPLETELY FRAUGHT WITH PROBLEMS
FOR SO LONG.
I THINK THIS WAS A REALLY
POWERFUL MOVE FORWARD IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THE MORAL
AND POLITICAL COURAGE TO BE ABLE
TO DO THIS WITH THE PROMISE HE
MADE TO THE PEOPLE AND HE
FULFILLED IT.
I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT AS WELL
COMMIT TO BE A PERSON OF YOUR
WORK, AS IT RELATES TO DEMONIC
RELATIONS WITH OTHER COUNTRY.
IF YOU SAY YOU'RE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING AND YOU MAKE A
PROMISE, YOU WANT TO WRITE I'M
VERY HAPPY THERE WASN'T A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF VIOLENCE.
PEOPLE WORRIED THINGS WILL
HAPPEN IF THIS OCCURRED.
IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN TERMS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP NOT ONLY WITH
ISRAEL BUT THE INVERTED STATES,
THE SAUDIS BEING ON BOARD, AND
NOW LET'S GET THE PALESTINIANS
TO THE TABLE AS WELL.
WHY NOT TRY?
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO BE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
>> Dana: THERE WAS SOME
VIOLENCE.
51 PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
THEY SAY THOUSANDS ARE INJURED
IN ADDITION.
MAYBE WE WILL FIND OUT MORE IN
THE COMING DAYS.
>> Kimberly: BUT DUE TO HAMAS.
>> Juan: NO, THEY WERE SHOT
AND KILLED BY ISRAELIS.
>> Dana: WERE THE ISRAELIS
DEFENDING THEMSELVES?
>> Juan: THEY WEREN'T.
>> Dana: HAMAS DOES TRY TO
MAKE SURE THE MEDIA IS COVERING
IT IN THAT WAY.
>> Juan: YOU GUYS ARE SO
ONE-SIDED I AM SURPRISED YOU
DON'T FALL OFF THE EARTH.
IT SEEMS TO ME IT'S SO CLEAR WE
ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE ISRAEL
IS ON THE OTHER SIDE LITERALLY
OF A FENCE.
THESE PEOPLE, YOU'RE 35,000
PEOPLE.
IT'S MUCH BIGGER THAN HAMAS, YOU
TRY TO LINK IT TO A TERRORIST
GROUP.
IT'S AN EXPRESSION OF PEOPLE WHO
FEEL THAT THEY ARE BEING RUN
OVER AND RUN OUT OF LAND AND
PROPERTY THAT WAS ONCE THEIRS
AND THAT THERE IS NO LONGER HOPE
FOR A TWO-STATE SOLUTION.
NETANYAHU HAS MADE IT VERY
CLEAR.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IT LOOKS LIKE BY
MAKING THIS HIGHLY PROVOCATIVE
MOVE DOESN'T CARE THAT THE
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEL
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEB
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAET
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEW
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEE
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAER
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEG
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEI
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAET
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEO
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEB
POTENTIALLY AS -- WE LOVE ISRAEE
THE FORCE THAT NEGOTIATED SOME
KIND OF PEACE.
THAT BROUGHT FINALLY SOME PIECE
TO THE MIDDLE EAST.
INSTEAD WE HAVE ISRAEL FIRING AT
IRAN IN SYRIA.
SYRIA UP IN FLAMES NOW.
WE HAVE UNSETTLED SITUATION HERE
BETWEEN ISRAEL AND THE
PALESTINIANS.
WHAT HAVE WE DONE?
WE ARE NO LONGER SEEKING PEACE.
NETANYAHU APPARENTLY CAN DO
ANYTHING HE WANTS.
THE PALESTINIANS FEEL GREATLY
AGGRIEVED, AND HAMAS NOW HAS
MORE MARTYRS AND YOU HAVE
EXTREMISM FUELED.
I AM INCREDULOUS THAT YOU SEE
THIS AS GOOD.
>> Dana: I DO THINK --
>> Greg: I CAN RESPOND.
>> Dana: I HAD A GOOD POINT.
IT ISN'T IN ISRAEL -- IT'S IN
ISRAEL'S INTEREST TO CALM THE
VIOLENCE.
SO THEY CAN LIVE SIDE-BY-SIDE IN
PEACE AND PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
HE BELIEVES THE STATUS QUO WAS
ACCESS TO THE HOLY SITES IN
JERUSALEM SHOULD REMAIN.
I DON'T THINK IT'S AS BAD AS
JUAN WAS SAYING.
>> Greg: I WANT TO STEP BACK
AND DIAGNOSE THE PROBLEM,
EXACTLY WHAT THIS SAYS, WHICH AS
WE BEGIN ON ONE SIDE AND WE END
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
THIS IS A PRISON.
THIS ENTIRE ISSUE IS A PRISON OF
TWO SIDES.
EITHER ISRAEL HAS A RIGHT TO
EXIST OR PALESTINIANS ARE
VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE.
THERE IS NO OTHER SIDE.
THE INTENSITY OF MEDIA COVERAGE
ON THIS ISSUE IS THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF THE LEVEL OF
UNDERSTANDING AND INTEREST OF
THE PUBLIC.
THE PUBLIC IS NOT AS INTERESTED
IN THIS ISSUE AS THE MEDIA MAKES
IT OUT TO BE.
THIS IS WHY WE DON'T HAVE ANY
MIDDLE EAST EXPERTS.
WE HAVE MORE MIDDLE EARTH
EXPERTS AND MIDDLE EAST EXPERTS.
YOU KNOW THAT WHEN THIS IS GOING
TO HAPPEN, THEY ARE GOING TO
CREATE PROGRAMMING POTENTIAL
WITH RETALIATION.
YOU KNOW THAT IF YOU SEND UP
THESE BALLOONS FILLED WITH
BOMBS, YOU'RE GOING TO GET IT ON
CAMERA, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO DIE
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS.
DOES THIS DISPLAY OF VIOLENCE ON
THE SUFFERING THAT OCCURS HAVE
ANY EFFECT IN THE LAND WERE FOUR
DECADES OF VIOLENCE HAS BEEN
HAPPENING ANYWAY.
CLASHES ERUPT EVERY SINGLE DAY.
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE ARE JADED AND CONFUSED ABOUT
THIS AREA.
I RESIST THIS IDEA THAT IT'S A
TWO-SIDED THING.
THE SOLUTION HAS TO ADMIT THAT
THE CURRENT WAY OF DEALING WITH
THIS IS GOING NOWHERE.
IT'S GOING NOWHERE.
AS LONG AS THERE'S ALWAYS GOING
TO BE VIOLENCE, THERE'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE VIOLENCE.
>> Dana: THE QUESTION OF
JERUSALEM IS NOW OFF THE TABLE.
>> Kimberly: NOT TO MINIMIZE
THE VIOLENCE AND LOSS OF LIVES,
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
THE PREDICTION WAS THIS WOULD BE
CATASTROPHIC AND WIDESPREAD AND
CREATING AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF